the EU Armenia Cooperation Council was
extremely positive Armenia was
independent sovereign sovereignty and
territorial integrity we support is a
very important partner for the European
Union we discussed together today the
next steps in our relationship as we
work on the signature of the new EU
Armenia comprehensive and announced
partnership agreement we are already the
first trading partner for the country
the first international donor and the
strongest support for reforms we're
ready to continue supporting our menus
reform process across a range of issues
including economic development the
business environment the judiciary human
rights the fight against corruption
issues that are very concrete and
relevant for the citizens over many we
have discussed today our shared values
including our commitment to democracy
human rights the rule of law which
underpinned the new agreements and our
future cooperation we are also looking
forward to our many s active and
constructive stance in preparation for
the upcoming Eastern Partnership summit
that we will held here in Brussels in
November this year
we also discussed the peaceful
resolution of the nagorno-karabakh
conflict the European Union believes the
status quo is unsustainable and that the
conflict needs an early political
settlement in accordance with
international law
thank you again Federica our consulate
includes very successful achievements
and deliverables during last period
since last council meeting were very
impressive in February here in Brussels
president Sarkisian and president tooth
announced the completion of negotiations
on the new legal framework of our
partnership and on March 21st Armenia
and that you have initialed the new
agreement in Yerevan we expect to sign
the agreement the brazos summit